michèle alliot marie jack lang annonce
le maintien du collège unique mais avec
des aménagements le ministre de
l'éducation nationale ne souhaite pas à
revenir sur le principe du collège
unique et républicains mais il évoque
une diversification en fonction du
niveau de chaque élève
l'explication helen hughes et jean louis
goût c'est redonner du sens et de la
cohérence parcours du collégien c'est
l'objectif de jack lang
dès la rentrée prochaine en sixième
l'effort portera sur l'accueil et
l'intégration des nouveaux élèves une
heure sera réservée dans les emplois du
temps pour répondre à leurs
interrogations en 5e et 4e des
itinéraires de découverte seront offerts
au choix des élèves travaux
interdisciplinaires qui doivent
permettre de préparer l'orientation
future
il ne signifie en aucun cas une
reconstitution de filières les
itinéraires suivis en 5e devront être
différent en quatrième sans revenir sur
le principe du collège unique la réforme
langue amorcent un début de relation
si la troisième reste la même pour tous
avec deux langues vivantes obligatoires
les élèves devront choisir une à deux
options parmi lesquelles l'option
découverte professionnelle elle pourra
être effectué en lycée professionnel
enfin le brevet change de nom et de
valeurs il devient brevet d'études
fondamentales obligatoire pour tous avec
une épreuve anticipée en quatrième son
obtention conditionne le passage en
seconde alors si jack lang a tranché le
débat sur le collège unique et bien ce
débat reste pourtant d'actualité
certains comme le ministre de
l'enseignement professionnel jean luc
mélenchon voudrait pouvoir orienter les
élèves avant la fin de la troisième
reportage
helen hughes et jean libon sert de
riches et là l'inégalité d'autant plus
visible visible météorique l'inégalité
dans le monde visible est bien réelle
l'inégalité dans leur environnement le
plus immédiat zones pauvres zones riches
ces élèves sont forcément issu de l'une
ou l'autre le principe du collège unique
c'est d'accueillir tout le monde mais
pour donner une chance à chacun certains
collèges sépare discrètement bons et
mauvais élèves
ici on les mélange nature génie t a
toujours des effets beaucoup plus
positif que négatif c'est à dire que le
pari parce qu'il s'agit bien d'un pari
c'est de faire en sorte que les bons
tiers jet privé vers le haut mais ça
c'est un pari comme tout tout ce qu'on
peut faire dans l'éducation
et comme dans tout paris il y as
forcément des gagnants et des perdants
là c'est horrible je n'avais pas du tout
à suivre
c'est toujours un maître-mot l'année
mathématiques de voir les meilleurs on
ça c'est un bon exemple je pense que de
vouloir travailler ça donne du courage
ça donne envie de d'avoir plus de bien
faire pour les bons élèves l'avantagent
de côtoyer de moins bons éléments c'est
d'être confronté à d'autres réalités
sociales
le risque c'est de ne pas progresser
autant qu'il le pourrait si j'étais que
une dans une classe avec des bons élèves
je sais pas je j'aimerais mieux pas
parce que niveau différent des fois je
projette de travailler tout le temps
meilleur de ce que je peux alors pour
que tout le monde y trouve son compte
les enseignants ces forces
d'individualiser au maximum
l'enseignement au sein d'une même classe
créer des groupes de niveau on
réexplique un point du programme au sein
pendant qu'on avance avec les autres
pour les plus faibles des cours de
soutien sont organisées pour les plus
forts des ateliers d'informatique
l'hétérogénéité est une situation qu'on
connaît qu'on sait gérer ou qu'on peut
gérer à simon a les moyens en revanche
le problème majeur à l'heure actuelle ce
sont les deux trois élèves a peu varié
d'une classe à l'eau qui sont en
situation scolaire très difficile et
dont le comportement petit à petit peu
devenir gênant vous verrez une solution
spécifique pour ces quelques élèves en
rupture scolaire sans remettre en cause
le principe même du collège unique
collège pour tous c'est l'un des
principaux enjeux de la réforme présenté
par jack lang
autre question